afghanistan's interior ministry says
three rockets have landed in separate
areas around the capital kabul
well they could be heard as afghan
president ashraf hani was
leading eid al-adha prayers at the
presidential palace
one hit behind kabul's most popular
mosque
another behind its largest shopping mall
the thirds
near the ministry of foreign affairs
there's no information
yet on injuries well diplomatic editor
james bayes
is in kabul for us james what more can
you tell us about these
latest rocket attacks and how
significant is this given its
the holiday of eids
well it's very dramatic and it's very
symbolic
it's worth telling you there have been
rocket attacks during eid before they've
been rockets attacks that have landed
in the presidential palace before but
i think coming at this very tense time
in afghanistan
uh it is a symbolic attack i can also
tell you uh that a senior taliban
official
in the last few minutes has confirmed to
al-jazeera that the taliban
were responsible for this attack the
afghan president ashraf ghani
at those prayers that you saw the
pictures of moments
ago at the end of the prayers he gave a
speech
and he said with their missiles they
wanted us to leave but did you see
anyone leave the prayers i think trying
to show that him and his key
government officials were very calm at a
difficult moment uh but
clearly again i think showing the
vulnerability
of the afghan government at this time
and james if the taliban are firing
rockets
into kabul on idaho how is this likely
to affect the ongoing peace negotiations
between the afghan government
and the taliban
well as you're aware there were talks
that took place in doha
ending on sunday and they appear to have
gone reasonably well
but the key thing that didn't come out
of those talks and which the
international community wanted which the
un wanted
was a ceasefire to mark this religious
holiday the talks could not agree
that they simply said that they would
meet again
soon to try and get a timely and just
solution
and would try to prevent civilian
casualties but clearly
for the taliban it's very clear that
they've not wanted at any stage
to have a ceasefire certainly on the
battlefield
they feel that in recent months they've
gained the upper hand and of course if
you have the upper hand on the
battlefield
that adds to your leverage uh in
negotiations
so i i don't think what we've seen here
in the last few hours
is a really big deal but i think it is
symbolic
and dramatic and again shows the
difficulties facing the afghan
government okay
james bayes al jazeera's diplomatic
editor live for us in kabul james thank
you